this is New Yorker cartoon and it has so
if you think about hunter who has like
the trophy heads on their walls like a
deer and I don't know what do people
hunt giraffe I'm not sure you guys head
on your wall really high ceilings
yeah rhinoceros head deer heads moose
heads whatever they might be
this one the the caption says I'm a
bargain hunter and then there's like
like a case of seltzer water on the wolf
yeah 12 pack of soft toilet paper it's
great cheese it's it's yes it's so easy
to cut and that it's like the group
hunting or not group hunting but the UM
what do they call a man like the extreme
couponers yeah yeah he just couponing I
mean there are people who who turn that
into a hobby and I go out of my way to
avoid the sort of coupon discount thing
if it's there and it's available I will
certainly use it I'm not gonna turn away
free money but I'm not gonna buy
something because it's a bargain just
because I have a coupon that shouldn't
be the thing that tips the scale toward
buying the thing hmm
what should tip the scale is it does
this add value is it gonna serve a
purpose is the best use of my money no
not uh-oh it's 15% off I'd be dumb not
to buy it right because of course it's a
100 percent off if you if you don't buy
it
you